media in myanmar are reporting that
police have shot dead protesters and
wounded several others in a crackdown on
protests against the military junta
tear gas water cannons and stun grenades
were fired into crowds
in various locations while scores of
demonstrators were hauled away
in police trucks authorities are trying
to crush weeks of demonstrations
against the february 1st military
takeover which deposed
the civilian government
and i'm joined now by an activist in
mandalay who would like to remain
anonymous so for security reasons we'll
be calling him
sam sam you're in mandalay the scene of
some very
violent police crackdowns on protesters
tell us what you've witnessed
yes i wanted to protest today and
the at least
eight people got injured and one is
confirmed
dead and he was shot to the head and
it was it is likely that he was shot by
the same
uh regiment that did uh
the killing last past last week
so you're you've seen some some um
quite disturbing violence on the streets
the police are obviously getting
increasingly violent in their response
to the protests
what effect is that having on the
protesters on the democracy movement
yes it's getting harmful
for us now because uh they they're not
even
you know following protocols or anything
anymore
and they i have seen today that they
also
shot at the ambulances and also uh
they went they uh they arrest people
that were uh that were sheltering
themselves in in the hospitals
so uh they're not they're not holding
back anything on protesters anymore and
they are
using extreme violence force against the
protester
and it is getting hard yeah and yet the
protests contin
continue now amazon sushi she's due to
face a court hearing on monday on
charges brought against her by the the
military junta
is she still what's unifying this
pro-democracy movement
or have things moved on
yes she is the embodiment of
freedom and hope for the normal people
and we have a saying in uh myanmar that
uh all of all of the card has their own
engine
so uh if one of us is taken out
we can still move on so i don't think uh
our you know fight for democracy is
gonna die off anytime soon
and we are gonna keep fighting till
we meet our goals so a defiant
democracy movement in myanmar sam a
pro-democracy activist in mandalay
thanks so much for talking to us
thank you